- Welcome to a conversation with history.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Amartya Sen,
who is the Lamont professor of economics
and philosophy at Harvard,
a university professor,
the 1998 Nobel Laureate in economics,
A fellow at Trinity College in England,
and he is visiting the Berkeley campus
as the 2005 Hitchcock lecturer.
Professor Sen, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you very much.
- Where were you born and raised?
- Well I was born in Bengal,
what was then undivided India,
about 100 miles off Calcutta
in a place called Santiniketan,
which is an academic establishment
where Rabindranath Tagore, the poet,
had established a school,
and then later it became an
institute for higher education,
where I also studied.
But my family comes from Dhaka,
which is now the capital of Bangladesh.
But I was born in the maternal parents',
maternal grandparents' home,
which was in Santiniketan,
and went back to Dhaka when I
was extremely tiny, I guess.
- Looking back, how did your parents
shape your thinking about the world?
- Well, I mean the family
was rather academic.
My father was professor of chemistry,
my grandfather was professor of Sanskrit.
So, you know, there was a lot of academic
prejudice within the family, as it were,
regarding that was a natural form of life.
I was born in the campus
in Santiniketan, in fact,
and spent most of my life
in one campus or another.
And my parents have too,
so in a sense, that was one
of the things of association.
But my father was, of course,
a scientist, he was a chemist who did
first physics and maths
and then did chemistry.
So there was a kind of interest
in science, which I had.
But my maternal grandfather
being a Sanskritist,
I had a lot of interest also in history,
in culture, and classics.
I did Sanskrit before I did English.
So I think there was a
kind of general interest
in academic matters, both
on the scientific side
as well as literary and cultural side.
My mother, actually, who
still is alive, 92 now,
she is somewhat reduced by age,
but still edits a
magazine, and in her youth
was an incredible dancer actually.
But that was many many many years ago.
- In your biography for
the Nobel Prize committee,
you emphasized the high
quality and distinctiveness
of your pre-collegiate education in India,
a place where you really
developed a curiosity
and came to understand
the importance of thinking
as opposed to making grades.
- Yeah, high quality,
one has to qualify that,
that is in terms of
being an exacting school
where you did everything, you know,
in as extended a form as possible.
Just in that standard,
Santiniketan was a high quality place.
In fact, things were very relaxed.
There was very little pressure
on you to do anything.
If you didn't want to do
much, you didn't do much.
So it was high quality in having
a rather different
philosophy of education,
which involved a lot more freedom,
a lot more choice, a lot more
interest in the whole world.
You know, not just India,
not just Imperial Britain,
but also China and Japan and Malaysia
and Indonesia and Thailand on one side,
and similarly, the Middle East and Africa
and the other European
cultures also quite a bit.
And a fair amount of interest
in the United States.
So we had a kind of internationalism.
The institution is called Visva Bharti.
Visva is world, bharti is knowledge,
so the motto of it, indeed the name of it,
indicates they were trying to
capture knowledge across the world.
So there was the internationalism.
There was a great deal
of emphasis on thinking independently.
And in these respects, yes,
it was a distinguished school.
On the other hand, I think
a lot of my classmates
in the same year in
Calcutta, or even Dhaka,
would have had known much more
in terms of the standard
school curriculum than we did,
because the focus wasn't on that.
- Given this background,
was it inevitable,
do you think, that the
focus of your life's work
would be ideas and the
importance of ideas?
- I don't know that anything is inevitable
in that sense in life, but
it probably did influence me.
Certainly.
But you know, we were, I've been,
even though I truly love hearing
and reading about great ideas,
my life has also been somewhat
involved with action, of course.
I was interested in politics
and I was interested in
activities of various kinds.
Including, the Nobel gave me a chance
to start two trusts, one in
India and one in Bangladesh,
dealing particularly with
elementary education,
elementary healthcare and gender equity.
And I've been very active in that research
in that area too, and intervention.
And also since I was, for three years,
honorary president of Oxfam,
that, as you know, is not a,
I mean it has a high ideology,
but it's also an institution of action,
and it's an NGO which is present
nearly everywhere in the world.
I was very privileged to
be associated with Oxfam,
which I still am, I'm no
longer honorary president,
I'm honorary advisor of them.
So I think, yes ideas, but
quite a lot of the ideas
have been concerned with
actions of various kinds.
You know, across the globe.
A lot of it in India and Bangladesh,
but quite a lot of it outside too.
- It sounds like there was a movement
toward a political philosophy
and economics as, there
were many opportunities,
from what you're describing,
of fields you might enter.
What pointed you in that direction?
- Well I think, I mean it
wasn't an easy decision.
I mean I was, since my,
since I went to school
at a place where my maternal grandfather
was a Sanskrit teacher, was teaching,
I was really very involved
in classical education
right from the beginning.
I started doing Sanskrit
when I was three, really.
So I had a lot of interest in classics,
but I also liked maths a lot.
And initially, in that battle,
thought that I might end up being
a mathematician and a physicist.
Which is how I began the end of my
school years and early college,
but then switched it to economics.
And actually political philosophy too,
but that came somewhat more slowly later.
I think I was involved
in student politics,
which played a part in that.
I was concerned with kind
of academic propensity
to generalize about ideas
and not particularize
about the action that I was involved in.
I think that naturally leads,
in a sense, to political philosophy.
That happened rather slowly,
and I think the development of
political philosophy interest
was not in the first days of college
which I had in Calcutta
in Presidency College,
where I was doing mainly
economics, economics and maths.
Having moved from maths and physics
I was doing maths and economics.
But then later on, when I went
to Trinity College Cambridge
and continued to do economics,
economics didn't seem very exacting
in Cambridge at that time,
and I had a fair amount of spare time
and I got involved with
doing philosophy generally.
Initially also philosophy
of science and epistemology.
But ultimately got very settled
on political and moral philosophy.
- How do you compare doing
theorizing in economics
versus doing it in political philosophy?
At one time, that universe was combined
in the world of ideas, at
least in the United States.
In the West there is a
more marked division,
although some people cross over.
Are there differences in the way
you think as you do these two disciplines?
- I think probably there is.
I would say a couple of things.
First of all, there is a much greater,
depending on whether you're
friendly or unfriendly,
you would describe it as a commitment to
or an obsession with, depending
on where you like it or not,
with quantification and with making
a very precise statement in economics
than you have in political philosophy.
I think most political
philosophers would tend
to say that the great ideas in the world
are not ones where precision
is the most important thing.
I think liberty, equality, and fraternity
are not bursting with precision,
but they're certainly
bursting with relevance
in the way they impact our lives.
So I think there is a
certain amount of division
about what makes something rigorous.
I think political philosophers would tend
to think that their type of rigor
is very different in the subject.
It's a point that
Aristotle makes very early,
that every subject has its
own level of precision.
And I think there there is a difference
between the standard way
the economists tend to think
and the standard way the
philosophers tend to think.
I think the other thing is that
possibly it's right to say
that economists have been rather
dominated by schools of thought,
so that if there is a line of reasoning
that becomes well-established,
whether it be general equilibrium
theory as it's called,
a kind of market-based thing,
thinking of everything in
terms of analogy with market,
or anything else,
and you know, people
quite often are making
the assumption that
people are self-interested
and trying to fit everything
in the world into it,
I think there's a presumptive difference
in the sense that economists often incline
to assume that, if there is a departure,
their first thought is
can I somehow accommodate it
by making the model a
bit more complicated?
And I think often political philosophers
won't go in that direction.
There I'm not sure that I entirely
agree with the mainstream
economics approach,
because I think trying to fit things in
and taking, as it were,
your established understanding
as the default program
to which you return if you cannot resolve,
not always the best way of understanding
not only political problems
but even economic ones.
Now since I have sort of run around
between these disciplines
a certain amount,
I think I owe a considerable gratitude
to the concern that economics has
with analytical and rigorous reasoning.
And yet, I think there is something
that political philosophers teach us
which may be of relevance
to economics too.
Mainly not to be too hung
up on precise statement.
After all, there's a whole maths
of incomplete orderings, partial orders,
precisely defined
ambiguities of measurement,
in which I think economics perhaps
ought to take more interest.
Political philosophers, of course,
typically don't go in the
direction of mathematizing it,
but insofar as the economists
are concerned with mathematizing it,
there's a whole area of mathematics
which can find bigger use in economics
than in fact it tends to get.
So I think in many ways
my own work and focus has ended up
being a little off center from economics.
And yet I think it's, I hope it's
strongly influenced by the
economic modes of thinking
as well as insight that has
come from political philosophy.
I hope so anyway.
- For a layman, myself,
a reader of your work,
there seems to be a very nice synergy,
in the sense that one has the sense that,
in what I've read, that you've
used political philosophy
to broaden the perspective of economics
when dealing with a particular problem.
That's a gross simplification,
but one definitely sees the energy
that comes from the interaction
between the two in your work.
- I don't now if it's
a gross simplification,
but it may be a little simplified.
But you know, as you
mentioned a few minutes ago,
that, at one stage, economics
and political philosophy was once closer.
After all, the founder,
or the person who had the greatest claim
to be regarded as the
founder of modern economics,
Adam Smith, was professor
of moral philosophy
rather than professor of economics.
And I think that connection
is still quite strong.
So I don't, I have not
had a sense of really
going outside the boundaries
of my subject, as it were.
I mean, I'm very keen on
interdisciplinary research,
but what is sometimes
described as interdisciplinary
is in fact just a broader
view of the discipline
rather than seriously getting
out of your, you know, field.
I mean, when you're doing, I don't know,
using evolutionary biology in order
to understand economic problems,
I think that is clearly interdisciplinary.
But when you're bringing in
a broader conception of human being
who is concerned not only
with his or her own life
but also with the lives of others,
commitment to them, concern
about them, and so on,
that doesn't strike me as quintessentially
outside of economics, that's
what economics is also about,
even if some models of economics
may not recognize that.
And classically, if you
think about the subjects,
the traditions, Adam Smith,
John Stuart Mill, Karl Marx,
Francis Edgeworth, I
think they have all had
very considerable interest in these
broader ways of characterizing
human behavior, human
understanding, and human commitment.
- You speak often in your writings
about broadening the base of information,
which has been very important
in your discussion of, for
example, choice and freedom,
development and freedom, that we have to
broaden how we see the
phenomena under question
to get new sources of information
to then explain and understand behavior.
- I think there are two issues here.
One is sometimes the information on which
the existing tradition
has tended to concentrate
and has got used to concentrating
may leave out something quite important
which are relevant and which
a different line of
inquiry might bring out.
For example, when I was working
on, say, famines and so on,
it became quite clear
that a food-centered view
did not give anything like
an adequate understanding of famines.
You really have to see it
as a much broader problem
with strong economic dimensions.
The markets of all kinds of
commodities are important,
not just food, because after all,
you have to earn your income
by selling whatever it
is that you have to sell,
maybe just labor.
But whatever it is you have to sell,
you're interested in the labor market,
you're interested in
those artisan products
which you sell on the basis
of which you will buy food.
So there's that kind of issue
as well as a political dimension.
Namely, some famines are
very easy to prevent.
A democratic society makes it obligatory
for a government to go in that direction,
because, you know, elections
are not easy to win
after a famine and it's
not easy to withstand
criticism of opposition
parties, newspapers, and so on
if you have a democratic system.
So it turns out, not a surprise,
that there has never been a
famine in a democratic society.
But this is not a statement about food,
it's a statement about the connection
between a democracy and famine.
So in all kinds of ways,
there are these information
which are relevant for studying a problem
which might have been left out
for those who took a rather
narrow understanding of,
in this case, famine,
just concentrating on food supply
and food availability
and food distribution.
The other thing is that
sometimes there are
real barriers to broadening
our understanding
because of high theory.
And this applies very
much to philosophy too.
A very good example would
be, say, utilitarianism,
which has been perhaps the most
dominant mode of thinking
for the contemporary world,
beginning with Jeremy Bentham.
You can trace roots earlier,
but Jeremy Bentham is probably
the big point of departure there.
But you see, there you
not only take into account
people's happiness and pleasure and pain
and desires and desire satisfaction,
but you tend to judge the importance
of absolutely everything in terms of
the intensity of desire,
the intensity of pleasure or happiness.
And that actually leaves
out a whole lot of things.
For example, if you're living in societies
where people are systematically deprived
and have relatively
little hope of redemption,
you know, kind of hopelessly precarious
landless laborers
looking for a little job,
overworked domestics servants,
women in a sexist society in which
women have very little freedom.
I think one of the things
that I did find observing
is that the underdogs come to
terms with their deprivation.
So if you're looking at
what their desires are,
by the time they've cut
their desire to shape,
it doesn't look as if their
desires are being unfulfilled,
it's just that their
desires have got adapted.
And similarly, people learn to take
pleasure in small mercies.
It's always nice to see, you know,
how in a terrible state of deprivation,
even in famine, people take tremendous joy
when they get a little relief,
a little food, a little security.
And in order to judge
how deprived they are,
if you went by the utilitarian calculus
of happiness and whether your desires,
whatever they are, happen to be fulfilled,
you would not recognize how deprived
the lives of these people are.
You need something a bit
more objective than that,
a bit more concerned with the actual
way their lives are going,
what freedoms they actually have.
And the fact that it's the lack of freedom
that might make them cut
their desires to shape
and train them to take
joy in little relief
in an otherwise terrible situation
has to be brought in.
But I think there you have to broaden
the information on this altogether.
The utilitarian base is utterly hopeless
in trying to get enough of an insight
about the nature of
deprivation in the world.
- You've spoken of poverty
as deprivation of capability,
as it would apply to the exact
situation you're describing.
- That's right.
Yeah, I think capability is
kind of a class of freedom,
namely what you can actually,
what you're able to do.
Are you free to lead a hunger-free life?
It differs from actually
leading a hunger-free life,
because sometimes, of course,
you may actually court hunger,
if, for example, you're fasting
for religious reasons or
for political reasons.
Mahatma Gandhi fasting,
you wouldn't describe the political fast
of Mahatma Gandhi against the British Raj
as indication that his life is deprived.
No, that's a part of his action.
So it's not so much whether
you're actually hungry,
but whether your freedom to
avoid hunger if you chose to.
Most cases you will choose
to, but there are exceptions.
So similarly, whether you have freedom
to lead a life with reasonable
clothing, reasonable shelter,
whether you have the freedom to get
medical attention when you're ill,
whether you have the basis of avoiding
premature mortality or
escapable morbidity,
all these come into it.
Or, for that matter, whether you have
the freedom to take part in
the life of the community,
kind of social capabilities.
So all these are actions
or functionings, as we
sometimes call them,
which are important for human life
and which we have reason to value,
the relative values of which
are for us to determine,
but if we don't have the
freedom to pursue them,
our lives are deprived in some way.
Now, poverty defined as lowness of income
is a very narrow perspective on that.
Certainly lowness of income tends to,
given other things, make us more prone
to deprivation of capabilities,
but we're not lamenting the
lack of income for its own sake.
We're really concerned with
what income allows us to do.
But income is not the only
factor which affects it.
There are so many other
things to be looked at.
If you're living in an
epidemiologically nasty region
with lots of epidemics of malaria,
cholera, whatever it is,
even with the same level of income,
your life might be more deprived,
you may be less free to avoid
these illnesses and so on.
So I think you have to
take a broader focus
and look at those things which are
really valuable for human beings,
namely the kind of life they can lead
and the freedom to lead that kind of life,
rather than something
mechanical like, say, income.
- Is it fair to suggest, then,
that one of the failures,
sometimes, of theory
is to simplify and to categorize
in such as way as to narrow the focus,
which then denies one
a richer understanding
of the phenomena in question?
- Something like that, but
I won't say exactly that,
because ultimately I
think we have to simplify
in order to have a comprehension.
I think, as T.S. Eliot said,
"Mankind cannot bear too much reality."
I think he's probably right.
But I think it really,
it's really a choice of simplifications.
Because it's the kind of simplification
which doesn't give us much understanding
compared with the kind of simplification
which will give us a lot of understanding.
That's what we are looking at, really.
So quite often it ended up,
and if you look at the
process of critique,
you get a model which
is, by necessity perhaps,
a simplified representation of the world.
You criticize it by saying
you're neglecting this,
this is very important,
you're leaving that out.
And then it looks as if you're
criticizing the simplification,
which, in a sense, you
are, at that moment.
But then, when you have really
broadened your understanding,
then you have a different type of theory.
And then, of course, in that theory,
you're trying to simplify again,
so that the bigger
understanding is comprehensible.
And in doing that you're looking for
a different type of simplification.
So ultimately, what begins with
a critique of simplification
replaces one type of
simplification by another.
I think that's my little understanding,
maybe very imperfect, of
the process of critique
and the emergence of an alternative
way of understanding the phenomenon.
So ultimately, simplification
isn't an enemy,
but we have to really be concerned
whether the simplification
is of the right kind,
you know, that would allow us to rest
rather than remain dissatisfied
and keep hitting at it.
- In the battle for redefinition,
for resimplification,
what are the wellsprings of creativity?
What are the roots,
and there must be many,
of the search for rethinking a problem?
You mentioned that you
were a political activist.
I assume that protest sometimes is,
in the general environment,
not necessarily on the
part of the theorist,
is something that changes our thinking
in this evolution of ideas.
For example, the case of the
women's movement in the '60s,
called our attention to many of,
many phenomena that had been ignored.
- I think that's absolutely right.
I think protest is very important.
I'm a great believer in the power
and reach of public reasoning,
and protest is one way of
engaging in public reasoning.
It's not the only way.
You could also have a debate,
which is not a protest but an argument.
So one would not like to confine oneself
to the sphere of protesting only.
On the other hand, protestation could be
both important in terms of what it's
immediately trying to achieve,
as well as the kind of
broadening of vision
that it may bring about.
Now just to take two examples,
you mentioned the feminist movement.
And certainly the feminist movement
has been one of the more creative things
happening across the world,
and quite a lot of it in this country.
The, I think what it was doing
was to question quite a lot
of the standard presumptions
about the nature of society that existed,
beginning with the family.
And family is an arrangement
where the divisions of the
fruits of living together
are determined by certain
established customs.
And, you know, that the
woman tends to cook,
can take a job if she can combine it
with the household work
as well, and so on,
which is the standard thing.
And this has become so,
had become so standard
and had gone on for such a long time
that people may not recognize
that there was anything special about it.
So I think you need some kind of a,
a kind of intervention of a sort,
which is not just a kind of
confirmation of what's going on,
which says why should it be
the case that this is so?
Similarly, whether the feminist cause
is just one where the women could pursue,
or the feminist cause us something
which is a broader perspective
which takes on an approach
to underdogs in general.
I was one of the founding members
of the association of feminist economists,
although I'm indubitably a man.
But I didn't see any
contradiction in that,
because it seemed to be a cause
that's of great importance.
To take another example,
I was in some ways lucky in being
in this campus where I'm now sitting down
with you today, namely at Berkeley,
in '64-'65, which was a year of,
you might recollect, free speech movement
and lots of things happened.
And I found it both a very
exciting thing to watch,
I was a very young faculty
member at that time,
but I was also, I think, learned a lot,
both from the way the organization
of the student movement went,
which was very different from
anything I was involved in
in, say, Calcutta, where my own
political teeth had been
cut in Presidency College
where I did take part in
student political activities.
But also, there was, I think, a kind of
transformation of
understanding in this form.
I mean, for example, before
I came to Berkeley in '64,
I would have thought that there were these
different trends,
different things going on.
There was the movement
about racial justice,
African-Americans, and that issue.
Hispanics too, but
African-Americans mostly.
Then there was also the issue
of the rich and the poor.
And then there was an issue
of the organizationally,
you know, the corporate
society versus the individual.
- The bureaucratization of the university.
- The bureaucratization of the world.
- Right.
- And I thought of them
as separate things.
And one of the more remarkable things
about the free speech movement,
and I think to a great extent
it's the vision of the student leadership,
is to be able to draw on
all these simultaneously,
which did not seem to
me to be very possible.
I mean certainly standard
left-wing politics
of the kind that Europe and Asia knows
seemed unlikely to get very
far in the United States,
given the political
territory in this country,
and the morbid fear of
communism and so on,
which dominated American
thinking at that time.
And that seemed to restrain things.
Now of course, at that time,
the fact that the Soviet Union itself
was going through great turmoil
really helped to broaden the perspective,
to say that, really, that's
not what the debate is about,
the debate is about
equity, about attention,
about the importance of
the persons in society
and not just of corporations
and institutions.
And in some ways the mixing of these,
well mixing is probably
not the right word,
the integration of these concerns
came to me as quite an
insight, a social insight,
which I think directly emanated
not from my reading of books
but from my observing of what was going on
in these rather unruly days in the campus.
It was certainly unruly,
there's no question.
A lot of classes were lost,
and for a teacher that's
always somewhat sad.
But what I was learning, of course,
was dramatically important.
So I think you're absolutely right,
that protests could be a
way of opening up the mind
and which could really broaden
one's understanding in a very big way.
- Another theme that I find
in my limited reading of your work
is the openness to diversity
and alternative experiences
as another source, a wellspring
of new ways of examining theories
and launching them on this path of
resimplification, rethought, and so on.
Talk a little about that, 'cause I know,
in a number of pieces that you wrote
in the New York Review book which read,
that this theme comes up.
Oh no, there was democracy in India,
or, you know, in China,
in very early periods.
So this, in a way, goes along with
a commitment to an existing theory
that's inadequate, basically,
because of its point of reference.
- It's very kind of you
to say what you're saying.
It's certainly been my
ambition to bring in
a broader perspective in many cases.
I think what happens
is that we tend to get
structured into thinking in certain ways.
And when they work very
well, to some extent,
it's like what you see in
the Agatha Christie detective stories.
If you find that a style of
doing crime works very well,
then you go on repeating it.
That's how you're easy to identify.
But that applies not only to crime
but also to creative work that,
once it works well, then
we like repeating it.
The person who was very good, for me,
was a shaft of light, true
shaft of light, is Adam Smith.
And this is, in a different
context, in a moral context,
but the same thing applies
to the pursuit of knowledge.
You know he had this notion
of the impartial spectator.
And he talks about why the
understanding of justice
requires you to bring
people from distant visions,
you have to imagine
what it would look like
to people who are far away.
And he gives us an example
that even the very
clever, very humane people
had tended to accept certain things
which would be hard for them to accept,
excepting that it had become
so standard in the society
in which they lived
that they don't question it.
One of his example is Aristotle and Plato,
along with all other ancient
Greeks and Athenians,
actually thought there was nothing
particularly wrong with infanticide.
Now, that may seem abnormal to us.
On the other hand, they lived in a society
in which that was standard practice.
And given that, given the fact that you
come to accept standard practice,
they did not apply their critical mind,
which they were applying
for almost everything else,
to this issue.
And the way to ask it, Adam Smith taught,
would have been for them to ask
does every society have it,
and if other societies
exist that don't, why not?
And in some ways, as you put it,
you need a vision from a
distance to look at that.
This is something that's
becoming important
right now in the United States,
given the divided judgment
in the Supreme Court
about juvenile capital punishment.
One of the points of disagreement
seems to have been, I mean I think
the primary debate, of course,
is about whether executing people
for having committed a murder
when they were a juvenile would
be cruel and unusual punishment.
Now I think the division isn't between
the two sides that they think
that you have to bring
in foreign perspectives.
I think the claim of the majority is that,
in fact, even in a domestic
perspective it appears wrong.
But in trying to understand
how the domestic examination would go,
there is considerable interest
on part of the five who voted on one side,
of whom actually I know only one
reasonably well, that's Justice Breyer.
There is a great deal of interest
in the way the world thinks about it.
It's not so much, as I
think Justice Scalia said,
in trying to do what others want us to do.
It's trying to, as it were,
broaden your own understanding
by seeing what things look like
from the perspective of others.
And then come back to ask the question,
what we as Americans ought to do now.
I think Smith was saying
something like that.
He was criticizing Plato and Aristotle
for not doing for here, but
doing it for other subjects.
So I think, to some extent,
the same thing applies in academia too,
that you get used to a, you know,
a certain economic model is successful,
we can explain market behavior
and a lot of other things that way,
and then we stick to it,
and then the question might be
do we have to do it like that?
Now if, in this case
it's not another country,
but if in another discipline,
they don't think that way,
then you may say, well, might there
be something to learn from that?
So it's that view from distance that is,
you know, you have to place yourself
at a certain distance to do it,
is I think the phrase that Smith uses.
I think that's quite important,
not just for morality and politics,
but also for epistemology and science.
And I think, to some extent,
that has been, you know, I
felt at least enthused by,
whether or not I've been
successful in doing it.
You referred particularly
to the issue of democracy.
I think it's quite standard
now in political philosophy
to understand democracy to be
not just voting, but public reasoning.
Government by discussion, I
think John Stuart Mill said.
That is very standard.
Now, then if you're looking
at the history of democracy,
you look not only at the
history of balloting,
you also look at the history
of public discussion.
And that you find all over the place,
from India, Japan, you know.
I quote Mandela from his native
village in Africa and so on.
So you have to look at the history
in a different light to understand
democracy and asking such questions
as to whether democracy can be,
quote unquote, imposed on other societies,
as if these societies never had
a tradition of public discussion,
which is just not true,
it's not true of the Middle East.
After all, there were very considerable
public discussion on these matters
in Iraq, in Egypt, in Turkey,
in Ninth Century Muslim
Cordoba in Spain, or in India.
When Akbar, the Mughal emperor,
was lecturing on need for tolerance
and for dialogue between
different religious,
members of different religions,
he was giving these
lectures at the same time
when Giordano Bruno was being
hanged in Rome for heresy.
And so, if one were to
look at it at that moment,
there's much more tolerance in Agra
than there is in Rome at that moment.
And it's not the picture
that the West has a kind of,
the monopoly of having taught
in a tolerant liberal
way and the East has not.
So I think that requires a
really big deliberation, I think.
- You're touching on a
very interesting subject,
which is the relation of
theory an truth to power,
because it would seem that power,
as it moved toward illegitimacy,
narrows the base of information.
Just as a response,
after reading your work,
that you touched on this notion of,
we've touched on freedom
and the notion of democracy,
which are now reputed to be major goals,
for example, of U.S. foreign policy,
but in fact the definition
of freedom and democracy
are very narrow ones
that limit the information about
different ways of thinking
about the concept.
So does this tell us anything about
the relation of theory and truth to power?
What can lead power to incorporate
new visions and not to limit information?
That must happen sometimes.
- I think the connection
between power and understanding
is quite important, I agree.
I think it is also a danger
in making into a theory something
which claims much more than is true.
So I think one has to
watch the rhetorical power.
As you know, rhetorical power has been
widely used in the social sciences
and sociology in particular.
Now, I think it's certainly true
that power, and knowledge is power too,
is extremely important.
And yet, it may generate the sense
that if you don't have power,
you cannot have any impact,
which I think would be quite wrong.
And even what we were
discussion about protest.
Is protesting about the
inequality of power?
And if you end up making an impact,
well you are making an impact
because you went against power.
Now then you might say somebody
might square the circle by saying,
of course, you had your power of protest.
But that way, I don't think
we are learning very much,
we are just putting everything
in the jargon of power.
But if by power we mean established power,
I think that to see
how important they are,
and your example about the American
role in foreign policy would
be a good example of that,
and at the same time how
it can be also challenged
to take the view that
since they have power
there's not a lot we can do.
I think it would be a great mistake.
And I think, in the context of this
particular thing are
mentioning about democracy,
I like the rhetoric of the administration,
the fact that they're
committed to democracy,
which wasn't the case earlier on.
After all, this country has quite a lot
of history of supporting
anti-democratic movements.
Military governments overthrowing
legitimate democratic governments,
whether in Africa or Latin America,
have often had support
from the U.S. government.
The fact that democracy is accepted
as an important, as least through
part of the rhetoric
of the administration,
in my judgment, is positive.
But then there's the question
as to how we should understand democracy.
And I think here there are three things.
One is that to see
democracy just as balloting
would be a great mistake.
That's not what the subject is about.
I don't think political philosophers
anymore think that that's
all that is involved.
And if you take, for example, Iraq,
it's not just a question of
organizing the balloting,
but also how much public
discussion there could be,
whether you can have the balloting
without banning Al Jazeera
from reporting in Iraq,
and whether the different
political parties
can express their views without putting it
in some kind of religious vocabulary,
of being a Shiite or a Sunni.
Can they raise the kind
of broader question
that the rest of the
world often brings up?
So there's that issue.
There's also the issue about
to what extent the organization
of political discussion
can be done without the kind
of militaristic atmosphere
in which Iraq inescapably is now involved,
given the way the thing went.
I mean, the error about the
weapons of mass destruction,
we can go on arguing about
how dreadful that error was,
but the fact of the matter is
that we are now in a situation
where you can't think of Iraq
except in a kind of form
where the military presence
and violence all around is very big.
And the third thing is
not to think of the world
only in terms of Iraq.
There's a whole lot of things
about democracy in the world
that one has to think about.
And one would need more commitment,
not just in the Middle
East, like Saudi Arabia,
but also in Africa, the commitment.
After all, during the Cold War years,
both the Soviet Union
and the United States
supported a lot of military dictatorships,
and the inheritance of that could
be seen in Africa even today.
The Soviet Union is gone and Russia
is a kind of pale successor to that,
but what is the United States going to do
in order to undo the
mischief of the Cold War
which visited Africa in a big way?
I think these are the kind
of issues to be faced.
Now I think, if we're being dominated
by one line of thinking
in the administration,
that reflects what you were saying
about the importance of power.
But on the other side, to
say therefore we have had it,
I think it's a great mistake.
I think if we have a different
view we ought to express it.
If Europeans think differently,
they ought to express
what their views are.
If others, Japanese, Indians,
others think differently,
we ought to express our view
and have a public discussion.
After all, public discussion has had
a considerable effect even on U.S. policy,
in making the administration decide
what is it that they can do
and what is it that they cannot do,
even though they are immensely
more powerful than any
other country in the world.
So that there is the danger
in the rhetorical power
of being too fatalistic and too accepting
of the, you know, going
too gently into the debate.
I think we have to vigorously engage
in these debates whenever we disagree.
- And you make the point, I
noticed in one piece that I read
comparing China and
India, of the importance
that a broader definition of democracy,
a reasoned discussion, can be
to the process of development, actually.
I recall that you make a point about that.
- I do discuss that.
You know, China has been, of course,
immensely successful as an economy,
and India is learning a lot from China.
China has been visionary
in two different ways.
I think, and both of these
happened without democracy.
In the government.
But the Chinese Revolution brought in
what was after all a popular movement,
namely the Communist movement,
and the Chinese, one must give
them credit where it's due,
went in for expansion of basic
education, basic healthcare
in a way that India didn't do at all.
And it's not altogether
independent of democracy.
It seems peculiar to think
that the Communist movement
is a product of democracy,
but after all the Communist
movement was a popular movement,
and they were replacing a
less popular government.
But then, that commitment
did produce a lot of results.
And in some ways the
Chinese were doing well
on the basis of this, much more
than the Indians were doing,
despite the fact the
Chinese also had a famine,
'59-'61, in which 30 million people died,
which India did not have.
But in terms of, you look
at trend of progress,
education and healthcare led
to all kinds of improvements.
By the time the economic
reforms came in China in '79,
the Chinese had a life
expectancy advantage
over India of 14 years.
The Chinese life expectancy
was 68, India's was 54.
And they were doing very much better.
Then came the economic reforms,
and it cured one of the
big problems of China,
namely an utterly
counterproductive economic system.
And then the Chinese economy started
growing very well, very fast,
and faster than almost
anywhere in the world.
But one of the interesting things
is that despite that, in this period,
even though the Chinese,
the gap between the Chinese
and Indian income had grown,
India was growing fast too,
like six, seven percent,
but the Chinese, nine, 10 percent,
had actually taken it much further ahead.
The gap between China and India has grown
down to per capita income.
But in the space of life
expectancy, it's halved.
In fact, life expectancy has grown
three times as fast in India as in China.
And also the gap in
infant mortality reduced,
if you take some parts of India,
which combines democracy with the Chinese
type of commitment to the poor,
which put China ahead of
India in the first place.
Like Kerala.
You see that Kerala's
achievement of life expectancy
is dramatically higher than that of China.
Similarly infant mortality.
At the time of economic reform,
Chinese and Kerala both had infant
mortality rate of 37 per thousand.
Now the Chinese have
come down from 37 to 30,
while Kerala has gone from 37 to 10.
And one has to ask what is it
that the Indians are doing right,
because it should go around.
And I have written on that.
There are dreadful things
happening in India.
Why is it that still it's going like that.
It would seem to appear that something
more dreadful is happening in China
for this gap to be reduced in this way.
And I think what's happening is I think
China is paying a heavy price
for not having democracy.
Because in order to have
constantly good health care,
you need public criticism,
such as baby hospital services criticized.
You can't have a situation
where a SARS epidemic
could surface in November
and be kept under a lid following April.
I think you need openness,
which a democracy provides.
But the other big thing is that
when China had economic reform in '79,
one of the first things they did,
and being a non-democratic country
it could do it in a drop of a hat,
is to abolish public health insurance,
so that you have to buy your
private health insurance.
China is one of the few
countries in the world today
where you actually have
to buy your vaccines.
And it's a situation
where you can't imagine
a democratic country where
the public health insurance
is accepted and agreed and
going on, it's suddenly dropped.
It can only happen in a country
with one party politics.
And I think China has
paid a very heavy price.
The Chinese life expectancy growth
has dramatically slowed down.
Infant mortality rates have stagnated.
It's to a great extent concern
with the absence of democracy in China,
which both allowed public health insurance
to be abolished and eliminated,
as well as, does not subject
the health service to constant criticism.
We know how dreadful the
Indian health service is,
but the saving grace is
exactly that we do know it.
There's a lot of public discussion,
there is constantly questions,
why shouldn't the government resign,
why shouldn't they do something.
I think that's very important,
not just in preventing
famines and big disasters,
on which I had written earlier,
but also in continuing progress
of healthcare, longevity,
and quality of life.
- One final question related to
looking at your life
in a broad perspective
and the richness and depth
of the ideas that you've grappled with.
And this is only an hour conversation,
we can't do justice to
the body of your work
and the beautiful clarity with which
your writings come to us.
What advice would you give students
who are planning for their future
about the kind of preparation
that should go into their education
if they wanna train for the kind of
theorizing we've been talking about,
which is really both, you know,
interdisciplinary, but
also questioning categories
and reshaping them and redefining them.
Any thoughts of advice for students?
- Well I'm not a great one to give advice
at a general level, I think.
I get very engaged in advising students.
I'm very proud of the fact that
I've had some really brilliant students
over the 120 or so people
who have done PhD with me.
And you know, some of them have done
much more brilliant work than I have.
But the, I take it you're really
thinking about the social
sciences, humanities,
because the natural
sciences I wouldn't even
pretend to have any advice to give.
I think this need to
question is a big one.
I mean that's so trite that
I hesitate to mention it.
But you see, I think the reason
why it's worth mentioning
is that sometimes the
discipline of the subject
as well as the academia
tend to discourage that.
It's much easier to publish papers,
for example, on a well-known subject.
If you look at economics,
you will find that the contributions
kind of come in clusters.
There was a decade when
everyone seemed to be
discussing about what the optimal size
and shape of cities would be.
Eventually I don't think it left
much impact on city planning.
If you talk with a city planner,
I don't think you typically get the idea
that they got a tremendous
amount from these
modeling of optimal cities
that were done in economics.
But one reason why it happened
is that, you know, while
something is going on
and one of the famous
names has written on it,
it's very easy to get a paper published,
criticizing a little,
changing a little, et cetera.
I think to resist that may be quite useful
from a long run point of view.
I mean there have been
such great thinkers,
you know, who have done that.
I mean, that has been the tradition.
That applies to all the big
names I was talking about.
But even among contemporaries,
if I talk, for example, of
my friend George Akerlof,
he's an economist who is here,
I think one of the reasons
why he has been so productive
is because he's always questioned things.
Right form the beginning.
You know, you say that this is
the standard way things happen,
doesn't seem to me so, why not this.
And then he tried to go
into the second phase
which we were discussing,
questioning one kind of simplification
but then trying to get a structure,
system, and analytical rigor,
which allows you to understand,
communicate, appreciate, fathom
in a simple way an alternative model.
So I think that kind of
willingness to question is important.
It's trite, but given the fact that,
quite often, academia
will encourage people
to go in the direction
of the easy success,
which is quick publication
on some established subject
using established methodology,
just completing the story.
You have done the north,
south, and west corner,
let me do the east, and
that's one more paper.
And that goes and it
adds to your curriculum
and you might actually
move forward quite rapidly
early in life, and that's
not to be scoffed at.
But I think the need to be skeptical,
even of the pressure of the academia
and of the pressure of
the department heads,
and I might say, even though I've had
good students and given them advice,
to be skeptical sometimes of the advice
that you get from your advisor like me,
I think, is very important, including
this very advice that
I'm giving right now.
- Professor Sen, thank you very much
for taking the time to be with us today.
It's been a real honor to talk a little
about your intellectual
odyssey, thank you.
- I really enjoyed it,
thank you very much.
- Thank you, and thank you very much
for joining us for this
conversation with history.